your chemistry with conan i mean
uh
when when camille non-gianni couldn't
make it on the show
and i
had to fill in for him as a guest yeah
it was an out-of-body experience to sit
on a chair in between the two of you i i
don't know if i ever told you that i
mean i i grew up like a lot of people my
age especially i grew up watching you
and conan on tv and so
you guys are like in my opinion the best
late night duo that's ever existed and
so when i
you know was filling in for male as a
guest i remember just being like i
cannot believe
that i'm sitting in between andy and
conan right now and then i know both of
them very well and they're friends of
mine and i
it was one of those things where i was
like i don't know how i got here but i
am so excited that i am here it was just
such a it was such a beautiful moment in
my brain at that point yeah oh it was i
loved it i i mean honestly you know i'd
you know
kumail's great but like he's not you
like
i always when people would say to me
like who are your favorite guests and
i'd be like my friends
like andy daley or matt walsh or will
arnett or you know or amy poehler like
that's you know like my when my friends
come on that's i don't would you know
like oh
you know tom hanks is there tom hanks is
a lovely guy but he's not like he's not
andy daley you know yeah that's true
yeah yeah it's not you
yeah and you have so many cool friends
andy that list was just so cool i know i
know i really do don't i yeah you do
but the hilarious thing is though that i
don't see any of them anymore that's
that's that's part of old age is i don't
see any of them if i have to list my
friends people be like who who
and you just listed the most legendary
improv people i mean it's like that's so
cool well yeah well i mean you know
that's i uh i that's your world that's
where you there was a a rigorous casting
process to be my friend and these guys
made the cut i'm honored i'm well now
let's talk about this book
you wouldn't be here just to chew the
fat you're here for a reason yeah i
don't want to be here just to talk to
you yeah
no of course i would do it even if i
didn't have a book but yeah i wrote a
book andy i wrote a book how did when
did that where did that come from so did
you say i think i should write a book or
did somebody come to you and say you
should write a book my my friend uh
liesel who uh a good friend of mine she
was like you should write a book and you
need to call it the world's worst
assistant and i was like okay
and then the next day i told you what is
is liesel in publishing or something or
is it just
or she just one of the kids from the
sound of music i know i forgot her name
is lisa
she was actually my college professor uh
she taught me um she was my speech coach
and i uh she was my speech teacher and
then i joined the speech team because of
her and oh okay um we've kept in touch
since college she's you know younger and
cool and she just like has really great
ideas about every she's one of those
people who's just like
you know make some make suggestions to
you about things you should do and
you're like yeah why didn't i think of
that she's one of those people what
you're like it's just it's good to have
her in my life and i love her and
she suggested it and i you know
i
i i was like it was like something i in
my head was like i should do that that's
fun and i
first needed to get conan's approval
because it's called the world's worst
assistant and i'm obviously gonna talk
about my time working for conan and he
was like i'm writing the forward
send it to my agents at wme and and so
he helped me get an agent he's writing
he wrote the forward for it so he was
really supportive i mean i couldn't
write the book if he wasn't because i
think it was for him and it would have
been really awkward yeah yeah
i work for a guy
yeah yeah
um
so yeah but i uh
it's it's it's it's a lot about
uh my time working for conan i mean it's
a lot of the things that we talked about
which is like there's always been sort
of like a fish out of water kind of
element to me and how i felt being in
television and working in tv so
a lot of the things i got to do like
when we went to the white house
correspondents dinner when you know we
when i met like you know bill clinton or
jimmy carter there was moments where i
was just like what is what is this like
how exciting that i get to do this and i
i've always told myself not to get jaded
by it not to
uh
not to
get too comfortable and think that i
deserve to be there so i've always had
this like wide-eyed wonderment about my
job and so i talk about that i talk
about uh
a lot of stories about
how much i've sucked at my job over the
years in certain aspects and you know
it's a lot of tongue-in-cheek because i
think when people think about
hollywood assistance i think they think
about these people who just are like
overworked and miserable and
they're you know constantly like
sacrificing their
personal and
physical and mental well-being for their
bosses who will like help them propel
them to a different
you know uh job that
will you know
it's it's a means to an end and i just
i think that it was i was like you know
i i feel like there's a there's a take
to my job which is
i
never had to do any of that i never had
to compromise who i was and my mental
well-being or my physical well-being for
this job and i
i got to a point where i was like this
is cool so i don't need to go anywhere
else like i'm i'm fine being conan's
assistant for the rest of my life and i
uh
i just i think that it was like that's
the sort of angle that i i
i wrote this book from was this
you've heard all these horror stories
about being an assistant but this is not
a horror story this is something that's
this was actually this is fun and this
is a fun take on it